Okay, guys. Welcome back to the computer
screen. We are going to move on now
further in our trade idea generation
process. Welcome to video 24, Quantitative
Processing 3. So we're getting pretty deep
now into the PTM video series. And I think
it's about time now.
that we introduce you to the quantitative
and qualitative dashboard. So if you
recall, in the first part of the PTM video
series, when we got to the end of the
first part, with our macroeconomics and
our leading indicators, we ended up with a
very comprehensive leading indicator
dashboard or a macroeconomic dashboard.
In the second part of the video series, we
are working on microeconomics, bottom up
processing. And this dashboard is the
quantitative and qualitative dashboard.
Taken together, our macroeconomics and our
microeconomics dashboard, create an
overall trade idea generation process. So
when you put these two dashboards
together,
you put these two dashboards together,
this is your key to the entire trade idea
generation process. Now, on the left hand
side, we have our most important first
step, quantitative sector filtering
metrics. So if you recall, from the
previous couple of videos, we have market
capitalization, earnings growth, revenue
growth,
revenue growth, and price earnings ratio.
In this video, we're going to be having a
look at peg ratio. We're also going to be
looking at enterprise value, EBIT and
EBITDA, EV over EBIT and EV over EBITDA.
This on the left hand side, this on the
left hand side is the area that is our
first step in the bottom up microeconomic
quantitative section of the trade idea
generation process.
In the middle of the dashboard, you will
see other quantitative metrics. And these
are all financial measures of a company
that we look to as traders and portfolio
managers, if it's required to, to do
further work, if we can't find our answers
in the first step.
Third, on the right hand side of the
dashboard, you will see the qualitative
area of the dashboard. So we have three
areas. Our first step, quantitative
filtering metrics.
Our other quantitative metrics that we
look to, to do further work if it's
required. And then we have our qualitative
assessment, which involves looking at a
company's key performance indicators.
Now, it's very important that we define
these areas of the dashboard as to whether
they are forward looking metrics or
backwards looking metrics.
In the first step of the quantitative
process, our most important measures are
the forward looking measures.
We then look to financial measures that
are backwards looking, both in the first
step and in the second step, in order to
fill in the bigger picture and to
understand companies better.
So we're learning more about the investor.
So we're learning more about the companies
and getting more information about a
stock.
And in the third section, the qualitative
section, we have both backwards and
forward looking KPIs that are unique to
the company and to the sector.
But without question, the perspective that
you should be coming from all the time is
that forward looking metrics are the most
important for making trading decisions.
And our backwards looking metrics are
essentially information to help us fill in
the bigger picture to simply understand
companies and stocks better.
So you're going to become very familiar
with the quantitative and qualitative
dashboard and the processes that we go
through as we make progress through the
PTM video series.
So don't worry about it too much at the
moment.
This is just a visual introduction of what
we've looked at so far in the trade idea
generation process with it micro and where
we are heading in the rest of the PTM
video series.
Now, as mentioned, we are going to be
looking in this video at peg ratio.
And unfortunately, or fortunately,
depending on which way you look at it,
it's unfortunate for people who think this
way, but fortunate for those that don't.
A peg ratio is as misinterpreted as PE
ratio by many individuals in the market.
A peg ratio is simply a valuation metric
that's built on the standard PE ratio, and
it's calculated by dividing forward PE by
forward earnings growth.
And we take the current year, which is
still forward looking and the following
year.
So it's worked out firstly as PE.
So the stock price live in the market
right now divided by forward earnings per
share and then divided by forward earnings
per share percentage growth.
So forward EG forward earnings growth.
Now in conventional or traditional
academic finance theory, we've already
seen this in previous videos when we
talked about price earnings ratio.
In traditional academic finance theory,
they will tell you high PE translates into
the word expensive, which is implying that
a stock or a company is overvalued.
And what would be the implied action on
that?
It would be to sell a long position or go
short.
In traditional academic finance theory, a
low PE translates into the word cheap,
which implies a company or a stock is
undervalued.
And what does that translate into?
What action does it translate into?
It implies to initiate a long position or
cover a short position, meaning you buy
the stock.
Similarly, because PEG is worked out as PE
over the EPS growth rate over EG, the
earnings growth percentage.
So similarly with PEG ratio, a high PEG
and a low PEG supposedly translates into
expensive and cheap respectively.
Nonsense.
Tear up your university finance theory
textbooks.
It's complete bullshit.
Cheap and expensive means nothing for
traders.
Something can stay cheap forever.
And something can stay expensive forever.
From the context of a PEG ratio.
A PEG ratio.
What does it represent?
It means expensive.
It means nothing for traders.
And something can stay expensive forever.
From the context of a PEG ratio.
Well, a PEG ratio.
What does it represent?
It represents the price the market is
willing to pay for a company's forecasted
earnings per share percentage growth.
Similar to the PE ratio.
There is no such thing as cheap and
expensive.
A PEG ratio can stay the same while a
stock rises and falls.
So, let's have a look at an example here.
Let's have a look at a stock that we've
just called Stock A.
The stock price currently live in the
market is $10 per share.
The forward EPS is $1 per share.
Therefore, the price earnings ratio is 10
times earnings.
A PE ratio of 10.
The EPS growth, forward EPS growth, is
20%.
So, what's the PEG ratio?
It's 10 divided by 20, which gives us 0.5.
Now, we can use the PEG formula to work
out some other very interesting and
important information when we wish to do
so.
So, for example, if we wanted to work out
last year's reported EPS without even
looking at it.
Well, that can be obtained by simply
discounting this year's expected forward
looking EPS by the expected EPS growth
percentage.
So, last year's EPS can be worked out by
taking the $1 forward EPS and dividing by
1.2, which is the 20% earnings growth and
we get 83.33 cents.
Of course, we would always check the
reported EPS because it's public
information.
But this is a good way of reconciling it
and making sure that last year's reported
EPS, we have it accurately in our trade
idea generation process.
And also that we have our forward looking
earnings growth correct in our trade idea
generation process.
Additionally, if we're sitting in the
market at any one moment in time and a
company announces, let's say, a material
change in business conditions and guides
the market to a lower forward looking EPS.
In this example, we've used 90 cents.
So, let's say, in this example, the
company that was previously expecting
forward EPS of $1, they cite a material
change in business conditions and they
guide lower to 90 cents.
Well, this changes the EPS growth estimate
from 20% to 8%.
So, we know our last year reported EPS
through our two methods.
Firstly, checking the publicly available
information as it's reported and also
reconciling with our previous forward
looking estimate of $1 of earnings and 20%
earnings growth.
We know that last year's EPS was 83.33
cents.
If they guide down forward looking EPS to
90 cents, then we can work out the
percentage earnings growth very easily.
So, we have to do 90 cents minus 83.33
cents divided by 83.33 cents, which in
this example gives us 8%.
What we can also do very usefully is solve
our PEG formula for P.
So, we solve for the stock price and what
we can do is we can solve it for the stock
price that keeps the PEG ratio constant.
So, we solve the PEG formula for P.
Now, if we plug in our numbers to our PEG
formula, our PEG formula is stock price
divided by our new forward looking EPS
number divided by our new forward looking
earnings growth percentage number.
So, we want to solve for the PEG and we
want to solve for the PEG ratio of 0.5.
We've rearranged the formula to make the P
and we calculate it as 0.5 multiplied by
8% multiplied by 90 cents, which gives a
stock price of $3.60 if we maintain the
same PEG ratio level of 0.5.
And if you recall, our original stock
price in this example was $10.
So, in this example, what has happened
here?
Well, the company has downgraded guidance
and guided the market lower from a forward
looking EPS number of $1 per share.
And they've downgraded to a guidance of 90
cents per share.
So, 90 cents EPS.
And what we can very easily work out from
that move in EPS is work out if the market
paid the same level of PEG ratio in the
new dynamic versus the old dynamic.
If we make that assumption, where will the
stock trade if it's valued by the market
under the same assumption?
So, in this example, a 10-cent move down
from $1 to 90 cents in forward looking
EPS.
By keeping PEG ratio constant, that
10-cent move has resulted in a fall in the
stock price of $6.40.
So, from $10, that's a 64% drop to $3.60.
Now, as traders and PMs, this is just
useful information to know for a couple of
reasons.
Firstly, we can look at the sensitivity of
valuation and stock price to a change in
EPS.
And don't forget, this could also happen
in the positive as well.
So, a company could cite a material change
in business conditions to the upside, not
just the downside.
So, we could use this formula to work out
upside as well as downside.
So, what we're doing here as traders and
portfolio managers is essentially working
out what the potential downside and upside
could be based on similar valuation
metrics in new dynamics.
Additionally, it also shows very obviously
that a stock can go down as much as it
wants and still be on the same PEG ratio.
And the opposite holds true.
A stock can go up to a level of whatever
it wants and the PEG ratio can still be on
the same level.
So, always, always, always, always
remember, a stock can go from any price to
its lowest price possible and still
maintain the same PEG ratio.
And a stock can go from its lowest price
possible to any price possible and still
maintain the same PEG ratio.
Cheap and expensive are curse words in
professional trading circles.
Nothing is ever cheap or expensive for
traders.
Okay?
Both price-earnings ratio and PEG ratio
are a signal of the quality of the
earnings of a company or stock.
Always think to yourself the following
when you're going through your trade idea
generation process.
We mentioned this in previous videos.
What price is the market willing to pay
for or willing to sell the earnings of the
company at?
There must be a reason why a positive
outlier trades on a premium to the sector.
And a reason why this negative outlier
trades on a discount to the sector.
And of course, always recall, there's
nothing you know that the market doesn't
already know.
And the market can always stay irrational
longer than you can stay solvent.
Don't argue with the market.
Now, when it comes to PEG ratio, as you're
going through your processes, you are
going to treat PEG ratio in the same way
as you treat PE ratio and earnings growth.
You're going to look at PEG ratio on a
relative basis within a sector.
So you look at a company's PEG ratio
compared to other stocks.
And here, we're going to be looking again
at Shopify, Wayfair and Overstock.
And in the table that should be familiar
to you by now, we have filtered here for
PEG 1.
So if you look at the chart, you can see
the column for PEG 1.
The PEG 1 for Shopify, if you look in the
column, is a total mess because of the
negative 0.22% number, which is in the EG
1 column.
So remember, the PEG ratio is the PE
divided by the earnings growth number.
And because of the laws of small numbers
here, the PE of 287 is divided by the
0.22% negative number.
So we get a crazy PEG 1 for Shopify.
The number could be very, very different
by tiny marginal changes in this 0.22
negative number.
It could be divided by 0, it could be
divided by 1, 2 or 3%, or even negative 1,
2 or 3%.
And we would get very, very different
numbers.
And this is going to happen to you a lot
when you go through your processing.
You are going to see some wild numbers
because of the law of small numbers.
Don't worry about that for the moment.
We are going to come on to this later in
the trade idea generation process.
Now, from our previous work on valuation
and on this sector, we learnt quite
quickly that in this sector,
the market is looking beyond current year
earnings.
So looking beyond year one.
And focusing also very heavily on revenue
growth.
Additionally, when we look at PEG ratios
for Overstock and Wayfair,
we learn some important information in
that we know Overstock has a higher
earnings growth 2 number than earnings
growth 1.
And if we have higher earnings growth
percentage in EG2 versus EG1,
then PEG 2 will be lower than PEG 1 as it
stands at that moment in time.
Why? Because we're dividing PE by a bigger
number in period 2.
Therefore, the PEG is going to be lower
than in PEG 1.
And you can see this very clearly in the
Overstock example where we have earnings
growth 1 of 7.26%
and earnings growth 2 of 64.66%.
We divide the PE by those numbers and we
get the PEG 1 and the PEG 2 respectively.
We get a PEG 1 of 9.23 and a PEG 2 of
0.57.
So what we're seeing here with Overstock,
not as extreme in terms of a move with the
law of small numbers as Shopify,
but the law of small numbers is applying
here in the first period because we have a
low earnings growth number of 7.26%.
So if we divide that 67 PE by 7.26%
earnings growth, we just get a high number
9.23.
A small change in that, perhaps if we
divide it by say 12, we'd see the PEG come
down by quite a lot.
But that earnings growth would be a very
small difference in EPS.
So if we divide it by 12, for example,
instead of 7.26, it would come out at
around 5.5%.
And because the earnings growth is jumping
by quite a lot from 7% to around 64, 65%,
we have a much lower PEG ratio for PEG 2
versus PEG 1.
Now, in the example of Wayfair, for
earnings growth 1 and 2, we do have, in
period 2, a much higher level of earnings
growth than in EG 1.
So EG 2 comes in at just under 152%
earnings growth, but we're coming from a
negative position.
So the PEG 1 is going to be a negative
PEG, and the PEG 2 is going to be a
positive PEG.
So the PEG 2 is not going to be lower in
this situation because we're coming from a
negative level.
So in situations like this, when you're
going through your trade idea generation
process,
it becomes pretty obvious that from a
trading and portfolio management
perspective, we can't really read too much
into the importance of the PEG 1 numbers
for this sector.
What is more important here is the PEG 2
numbers, not simply because the numbers
are all skewed and messed up in period 1
for PEG 1,
but also because we know from our previous
work, what we know about this sector is
that the market is looking past current
year earnings and looking towards next
year's earnings,
and also focusing a lot on revenue growth
as well.
So in a situation that's typical to this
outcome, we have to filter for PEG 2.
And when we look at Shopify, the PEG 2 now
comes out at 9.45.
This is obviously a very high PEG.
And we obviously read into it as a
positive sign.
But of course, 9.45 for a PEG ratio is
pretty insane.
We'll come on to this in a moment about
sensible levels of assumptions for PEG
ratios from a trading and portfolio
management perspective.
But we do take it as positive.
We take it as a signal of the quality of
the revenue and future earnings of
Shopify.
That's what the market seems to be paying
for.
As traders, we acknowledge it and allow
long-term investors to have their fun in
the stock and hold the baby.
Non-participation for us is an option.
If you remember, we eliminated shop as a
potential trade idea due to the size of
its market cap.
So as traders, we don't argue with the
market.
We just step back.
We choose to not participate.
And we allow long-term investors to invest
in Shopify at the valuation that they
believe is justified at this moment in
time.
And we allow them to hold the baby.
For us, non-participation is an option.
And for the record, later in the trade
idea generation process, we will further
explain why very high market cap stocks
are eliminated from a traders process.
Now, if we look at Wayfair and Overstock
on a PEG-2 basis, Wayfair has a PEG-2 of
0.42 and Overstock has a PEG-2 of 0.57.
Now, we initially, firstly, interpret this
in a negative manner for Overstock, for
example, because we ask ourselves the
question, why?
What's the reason?
There must be a reason.
Is the market willing to sell the quality
of the 2022 earnings growth?
However, we also acknowledge that the
stock is trading now and trades every day.
So there may be an expectation of period
two already in period one and in the stock
price.
So we acknowledge that there is a conflict
here in the numbers in that Overstock's
PEG-1 is 9.23.
So in a situation like this, we can revert
to our Solve4P formula.
So we can work out for the PEG to remain
the same in 2022 versus 2021.
What does the stock price cut out us?
Well, when we Solve4P, we're multiplying
9.23 by the 64.66% EG-2 earnings growth
number.
And we multiply that by $2.19 EPS.
And we get to a stock price of $1,307 with
a current share price in the market of
Overstock of $80.
Now, this is obviously ridiculous because
the 9.23 number is very heavily skewed in
a PEG-1
because of the law of small numbers in the
EG-1 number for Overstock at 7.26% that we
mentioned previously.
But we can make some assumptions here.
We can apply a normal healthy PEG ratio,
which in the financial markets is between
1 and 2 for a company that trades on a
premium to its earnings growth.
So its PE is trading on a higher number
than its earnings growth.
So a normal and healthy PEG ratio that
signifies a market endorsement
traditionally is around 1 to 2.
In the Overstock example, the market here
must be paying a premium now for something
else in the future.
And if we recall from previous videos, the
revenue growth of Overstock in 2022,
period 2, was 15.62%.
That was the forecasted number for
Overstock revenue growth in 2022.
And that number was higher than in all
previous years to the COVID-19 economic
lockdown year in 2020.
So the market is possibly looking through
year one and looking to year two, 2022,
and looking at revenue growth and giving
benefit to the stock price now.
Now, and this is reflective in the PEG one
number.
And obviously reflected in the one year
forward current year PE ratio, which if
you recall is 67.
And that's divided by a low earnings
growth number in period one.
So to get that PEG ratio in year one of
just above nine, you not only need a low
earnings growth number, but you also need
a high PE ratio.
So it's possible here that in year one,
the current stock price in Overstock and
the PE ratio is creating a high PEG ratio
because of the low earnings growth,
because the market is looking through the
current year and looking at the revenue
growth in period two.
And of course, not only revenue growth is
important here for the market in 2022, but
also earnings growth in period two is
obviously very important.
So we know that for overstock, we know
that for overstock, the earnings growth in
period two is 64.66%.
So if we make the assumption that PE ratio
and PE ratio in 2021 in period one is
somewhat reflective of what is occurring
in period two with revenue growth of
15.62% and earnings growth of 64.66%.
We can make an assumption here of the
market potentially rewarding overstock if
they deliver on these numbers in period
two by putting the stock on a PEG ratio of
one.
And then we can solve for P, we can solve
for stock price.
And when we do this, it's quite
interesting because when we solve for P on
a PEG ratio of one using the EG2 64.66%
and the EPS in period two, we get to a
stock price of $140.60.
So if the market rewards overstock on a
PEG ratio of one in period two, the stock
price has potential upside here to
$140.00.
And this is from a current stock price at
the time of recording for overstock of
$80.00.
So this would represent a 75% increase
approximately in the share price over a
one-year period.
Now what else is interesting is if you
look at the difference in the PE ratios
between period one and period two for
overstock.
In period one, we had a PE ratio of 67%
and in period two, we had a PE ratio of
36.67% and the difference between the PE
ratios is around 80%.
So moving forward from period one to
period two, if the stock price becomes
reflective of fundamentals in period two
and overstock trades on the same PE
multiple in period two versus period one,
which is 67% and we make a reasonable
assumption that the market rewards
overstock.
If the stock price rewards overstock for
hitting its numbers, then we get to a
share price of roughly $140.00.
This outcome combined with the EPS kicker
that overstock gets from paring down its
R&D spend, which we went over in the
previous videos, provides us as traders
with upside potential.
And we've gone through our process here
and recognize this.
At this moment in time, it's an
identification process.
We have identified a positive outlier that
now has potential upside.
And the market, it's clear, possibly
thinks this too.
The question really is whether it's
probable.
So the future stock price outcome of
overstock is probably going to be
determined by the management's ability to
stay on track and keep reiterating the
15.62% revenue growth or even better than
that for 2022.
And maintain profitability as a company
coming from a loss-making position in
previous years, whilst paring down R&D
spent.
On current valuations, it seems the market
is expecting them to be able to do this to
an extent.
But they're not giving the full benefit to
the company yet.
They need to deliver.
So on current valuations, the PE is
reflective, the high PE of 67 now is
reflective of an expectation from the
market that they're going to be able to
deliver to an extent.
We say to an extent.
We say to an extent because when you
combine this with a PEG ratio of 0.5
that's lower than a PEG ratio of 1, it
means that the market is not giving them
the full benefit of delivering on this
revenue and earnings growth in period two.
If they deliver, then the stock will
probably trade on similar multiples from a
PE perspective in period two versus period
one and will probably trade on a PEG ratio
that's one or higher.
And of course, no one said that in
financial markets and especially in
trading, there's no such thing as risk.
If they don't deliver on this, the market,
the stock will get killed.
The market will punish the stock.
So they need to deliver on the 15.62% of
revenue growth or better for 2022.
And they need to make sure the needle of
profitability is moving in the right
direction whilst paring down R&D spend.
If they do that, the market will probably
reward them.
If they don't do it, the markets will
probably punish them.
So if they are rewarded, they will trade
on the same or higher multiple in period
two versus period one.
And the stock will be essentially
re-rated.
If they don't deliver, the stock will get
punished and trade on a lower multiple in
period two versus period one.
And the stock will be re-rated to the
downside or de-rated.
Now, as mentioned many times throughout,
and it's worth mentioning again, the
process here is what is important.
We will always go through similar
processes in every situation.
We have price earnings ratio, earnings
growth, peg ratio, and market cap measures
relative to peer group.
So we have these measures for a stock
relative to peer group, to a sector.
And we locate positive and or negative
outliers in a sector.
And we ask the obvious questions while
sticking to our traders' interpretation of
valuation metrics.
We keep asking and we keep digging.
As we're going through the process, we
interpret what messages the market is
telling us and try to come to logical
conclusions.
And of course, every situation will be
different and will have to be interpreted
on its own merits.
But don't worry, this comes with
experience and practice.
At ITPM, we've had many people start off
with no clue what to do.
And within three to six months, they know
how to interpret things properly in pretty
much all situations.
It's down to process, it's down to
practice, it's down to common sense and
logic.
Now we're going to be moving on to having
a look in our first step of the
quantitative filtering process.
We're going to move on to looking at
backwards looking financial measures.
So in our example that we've been through
so far in the last few videos, where we're
looking at Shopify, Wayfair and Overstock.
And we've been through the identification
process of the positive outliers and
started to understand what the market
likes and dislikes and possible reasons
why.
So this next step is what you would start
doing if you wanted to take it further and
start learning all of the past information
of, for example, Overstock and start
looking at it in comparison to, say,
Shopify and Wayfair and even other stocks
in the sector.
What we're doing here is looking at some
key backwards looking financial metrics to
fill in the bigger picture and fill in
some of the gaps to understand the full
picture of the story in the sector.
And of course, by going through that
exercise, we will start learning a lot
more about the individual stocks that
we're potentially thinking about looking
at for long and short ideas.
But this type of analysis does come with
caveats, not only because it's backwards
looking information and we are traders and
we look forwards, but also because of the
way as traders we interpret valuation
metrics, which is different to the way
most people in the market or traditional
finance teaches.
But it is still necessary, even from a
trading and portfolio management
perspective, to not go into the market
blind.
We still have to go through these
processes to fill in the gaps and fill in
and understand the bigger picture.
What we're going to do in this part of the
video series is show you how these
financial measures are calculated, how
they are defined and how we interpret them
as traders and portfolio managers and with
the caveats as well.
So when you're going through this part of
the process, you'll understand and
interpret these numbers a lot better than
most people in the market.
Okay, so let's first put backwards looking
quantitative measures into context here in
our trade idea generation process.
So far, we've looked at forward looking
valuation and growth measures in the
quantitative phase of the bottom up
section of our trade idea generation
process.
And you can see the metrics that we've
looked at here on the screen market
capitalization, earnings growth, revenue
growth, PE ratio and PEG ratio.
From those forward looking valuations,
market capitalization includes price and
is forward looking, price earnings ratio
and PEG ratio, obviously also include
price and are forward looking and earnings
growth and revenue growth are percentage
differences based on forward looking
estimates of EPS and revenue.
In the first part of the bottom up section
of the trade idea generation process, so
our first quantitative phase, there are
however, further measures we can use to
extend our knowledge about a sector and
stocks within a particular sector.
So these are enterprise value, EBIT, EBIT
and EBITDA, EBIT over EBIT, so enterprise
value over EBIT and EBIT enterprise value
over EBITDA.
But we have to remember as traders and
portfolio managers, we are forward looking
animals.
And these measures are all backwards
looking and are taken from a company's
publicly available annual accounts for the
previous year.
As traders, we want to always be looking
forward.
However, we can use these backwards
looking measures and compare sector peers
to each other on these metrics to get a
better understanding of the sector and
stocks.
So let's start here with enterprise value,
EV, what is it? What does it do?
Well, enterprise value attempts to measure
a company's total value.
It's a similar measure to market
capitalization, but with a twist.
So market cap is the live share price in
the market multiplied by the outstanding
shares in issue.
And enterprise value is equal to the
market cap plus the total debt of the
company minus the cash that the company
has.
So what enterprise value does is it
captures the value of a company in theory
if it were to be taken over.
So, for example, let's say a company has a
market cap of $10 billion, but had $6
billion of total debt and a positive cash
position of $1.7 billion.
The enterprise value of this entity would
be the market cap of $10 billion plus the
debt of $6 billion minus the $1.7 billion
of cash, which gives us $14.3 billion.
So if an acquirer came in to this company
and wanted to buy the company outright at
the current market cap, it would have to
pay off the debts, but would use the cash
towards paying off the debts.
So they would end up paying $14.3 billion
in total.
So acquiring the equity, the debt, and the
cash.
Now, there are, from a trader's and
portfolio manager's perspective,
limitations and caveats that do come with
the calculation of enterprise value.
Firstly, there's a big question always
over any company that has debt.
The question is, how is the debt actually
being used?
And there is an overlap with our second
consideration here, which is the quality
of operations at the company itself.
Thirdly, the market knows the debt and
cash position of the company already.
It's not like people in the market don't
understand from the last set of accounts
what the debt and cash position is of a
company.
The market knows this.
And lastly, it's obviously backwards
looking.
So firstly, let's deal with how the debt
is being used.
So if you are looking, for example, at
sector data in a table and comparing, say,
20 stocks market cap and enterprise value
to each other,
you may go through the process of locating
stocks that have a lot more debt and lower
cash positions than others.
Now, does this mean it's a bad stock?
Not necessarily.
It's important to remember that enterprise
value does not measure how the debt is
being used.
So you have to actually go and do the work
to figure out how the debt is being used
and what the debt is actually financing.
If, for example, the debt is being used to
fund highly profitable current and future
operations and very efficient operations,
then you're probably going to see this
reflected in the market cap of the stock
already,
because the market looks forwards, not
backwards.
How debt is being used by the company is
very important.
So when you're comparing all of these
stocks, just because a company has high
debt and lower cash levels than others,
it doesn't mean it's a bad stock in the
sector.
So the quality of operations at the
company really matters.
Simply looking at the EV of a stock and
comparing it to another stock's EV may not
add any value to our analysis if we're
already using market cap.
The question is here is, is it really
going to tell us anything new other than a
statement of where it is?
A relative EV appraisal must be done
within the context of the quality of the
operations at the companies.
So if you haven't analyzed the operations,
you can't deduce whether enterprise value
is a positive or a negative for a stock
relative to other stocks.
So when you're going through your process
of analyzing EV on a relative basis, you
must bear this in mind.
You have to learn the operations
themselves and there's many measures of
the quality of operations and it's totally
dependent on the sector that you're in.
Now this comes later in the trade idea
generation process in the PTM video series
with our qualitative analysis and key
performance indicators.
Now, additionally, with enterprise value,
we have to understand as traders that the
market obviously knows the debt and cash
position of the company already.
The market really isn't that stupid. Do we
really think that the market doesn't
already know what the debt and cash
position of a company actually is from
their last set of annual accounts?
When we look at market capitalization,
it's simply the price that the collective
market is willing to pay for the entire
company given all available information.
So market cap is therefore a function of
every consideration already, including the
debt of the company, the cash position of
the company and the quality of the
operations.
Now, we as traders are by no means
believers in efficient market hypothesis.
So the idea that a company stock price is
a function of perfect information, we
would not be traders if this were true or
if we believed that this was true.
However, it's pretty obvious that the
collective market can't be dumb enough to
not already know the outstanding debt and
cash position of a company in its last set
of publicly available accounts.
We have to assume that they see what we
see, they see it and the price the market
pays for the stock.
So the market cap is a function of this
plus forward expectations of business
operations.
Hence why, as traders, forward looking
measures are way more important to us.
Which brings us on to our next point,
which is forward looking versus backwards
static numbers.
So forwards looking dynamic numbers versus
backwards looking static accounting
numbers.
So in the EV calculation, the market cap
number is the dynamic number within the
calculation.
And it's changing every microsecond based
on forward looking expectations.
The debt and the cash position numbers
within the EV calculation are static to
the point of the company's last annual or
quarterly update.
A company can take on more debt or pair
down debt plus the cash position could
change.
In the last set of accounts, for example,
it may state a particular number for debt
or cash.
But this can be meaningless if the
company, for example, is providing
guidance that they intend to eliminate a
lot of debt and make, say, business
disposals in the next one to two years to
pay off a lot of debt.
So in this situation, for example, this
would now become a forward looking
qualitative measure and will likely get
reflected in the market cap at some point
well before the financial statements are
updated.
So with these limitations, the obvious
question is, is why as traders would we
even look at enterprise value?
Well, it's a good question, but it's for
context.
We want to have a look at the landscape of
a sector and look at the EV numbers, which
include our market cap plus debt plus cash
position of every company relative to each
other, just to understand what the
landscape is.
Additionally, we can use enterprise value
and our other backwards looking financial
metrics as either supporting or non
supporting evidence.
So either confirming or non confirming
evidence of our valuation multiples like
price earnings ratio and peg ratio.
So for example, when we work out
enterprise value across an entire sector
and we're looking at a positive outlier
that has a high PE and a good high peg
ratio forwards looking in our valuations.
If we then look at market cap and
enterprise value and we see that there's
not much difference between enterprise
value and market cap, it may mean that the
company has low debt levels and fairly
strong cash position.
If we look at market cap, it may be a
positive outlier, which could be a driver
or supporting evidence of the high PE
multiple and the high peg ratio relative
to other stocks in the sector.
However, what happens if we put our tables
together, we work out all of our EV
calculations and then we see a positive
outlier high multiple for PE.
We see high PE, we see high PE, we see
high PE ratio and then we see a very high
and big difference between EV and market
cap.
Well, that just means that the company has
got like large debt levels and possibly
low cash levels.
And this would be non-supporting or
non-confirmation for our high multiple PE
and our high PE ratio.
So this would be conflicting information.
And of course, in either case, we always
take it to the next stage and we put it in
the context of the quality of the
operations.
But in that situation, as traders and
portfolio managers, we still interpret the
high multiple PE ratio and the high PE
ratio in that the market must be paying
for something else at the company.
And in that situation, it's highly likely
that it's to do with the quality of the
operations.
The key point to take away here is that
it's part of the process and we follow the
process and it's repeatable for all
sectors throughout time.
And we go through this part of the process
as the first part of the trade idea
generation bottom up section of the
overall process in order to get context.
So when we look at valuation, we either
see confirming or non-confirming
information and then we ask further
questions and we continue our further
lines of inquiry.
By going through these processes, we are
information gathering.
We are learning more information about the
sector and stocks and understanding the
context of each stock within the sector
relative to its peer group.
The more information we have, the better
understanding we're going to have about a
particular sector and stocks within the
sector as long as we interpret the numbers
correctly and continue logical lines of
inquiry and ask the right and obvious
questions.
Next up in our backwards looking financial
measures is EBIT and EBITDA.
Now, the difference between EBIT and
EBITDA is that depreciation and
amortization have been added back to
earnings in EBITDA while they're not added
back to EBIT.
So the definition of EBITDA is earnings
before interest, taxes, depreciation and
amortization.
And EBITDA is net earnings plus interest
expense plus tax expense.
And EBITDA is net earnings plus tax
expense plus depreciation plus
amortization in the financial accounts.
Now, EBIT is often referred to as
operating income.
So the company's earnings prior to paying
interest to creditors and taxes to the IRS
on those earnings.
And with EBITDA, that is operating income
with depreciation and amortization added
back to profits.
Now, we have to be careful with these
measures and understand that these
measures are contextual to sectors that
we're looking at.
So EBITDA, for example, since depreciation
isn't captured by EBITDA, it can lead to
profit distortions for companies that have
a sizable amount of fixed assets and
subsequently substantial depreciation
expenses.
The larger the depreciation expense, the
more it's going to boost the measure of
EBITDA.
So there are limitations to this and
everything has to be contextual to the
sector that we're looking at.
Both measures have limitations, but let's
see what it looks like first to understand
the picture a little better.
So we have on the screen here the
financial statements for 2018 and 2019 for
a random company.
And if you look on the left hand side,
we're looking at calculating here the
EBIT.
So EBIT is net earnings plus interest
expense plus tax expense.
So net earnings for this company are
$39,860,000,000.
The interest expense is $500,000,000.
And the taxes are $15,501,000,000.
So we add all of these together.
So from the net earnings number, we are
adding back the interest expense and the
taxes to get to $55,861,000,000 EBIT.
If you look on the right hand side, we
have the same financial statements.
But this time to get to EBITDA, we are
adding on to EBIT depreciation and
amortization.
And you can see in the set of accounts on
the right hand side and even on the left
hand side, it's the same set of accounts.
You can see the line item for depreciation
and amortization for 2019 comes in at
$15,03,000,000,000.
So we add this onto our EBIT calculation
to get EBITDA of $70,864,000,000.
And if you haven't noticed yet, this is
obviously a very big company in 2021 in
the United States.
Very big earnings number, EBIT and EBITDA
number.
This will be a top company in the S&P 500,
something like an Apple.
So now that you've seen how it's
calculated, it's a lot easier to
understand its usefulness and limitations.
So the usefulness and limitations of both
EBIT and EBITDA calculations.
Now, the most obvious limitation is that a
company can be making money operationally,
but losing money on a net basis.
At the end of the day, guys, interest
expenses, taxes, depreciation and
amortization are real things.
And if a company can't make money on a net
basis, who really cares if they are
operationally profitable?
So we have to be really careful here when
analyzing EBIT and EBITDA.
And of course, when we analyze any stock
in a sector and a stock relative to other
stocks in the sector, there's obviously
many things in the financial statements to
consider.
So like, for example, in our Shopify and
Overstock example with their R&D spend.
R&D spend is obviously an important factor
for these stocks and that sector.
And we could even add R&D spend back to
earnings too.
We can theoretically keep adding
everything back till we get back to just
revenue.
But that wouldn't be a useful exercise for
us.
The usefulness of EBIT and EBITDA measures
tends to be highly dependent on which
sectors we are looking at.
So, for example, EBITDA is a more useful
measure of operational performance in the
oil and gas sector, mining sector,
manufacturing and infrastructure sectors
than, for example, the service sector.
So highly capital intensive industries.
Why?
Because they have very large DNA numbers,
very large depreciation and amortization
numbers.
So when those get added back in, the
EBITDA number flatters the operational
performance of the company.
So EBIT is a much better measure or more
useful measure for operational performance
in those sectors.
EBITDA is a more useful measure or tends
to be a more useful measure than EBIT in
industries with a low capital expenditure.
So low CAPEX.
The DNA numbers are very small in these
sectors, even non-existent.
So here it's a good measure for cash flow.
So with EBIT and EBITDA, we can compare
companies in the same sector to figure out
which ones have struggled in the past
operationally versus those that have
excelled operationally.
And we can then identify the reasons why
later in our trade idea generation
process.
So we look at the qualitative elements
that drive the operational performance
later.
And then we put this into context as
supporting or non-supporting evidence of
our valuation multiples, price earnings
ratio and PEG ratio.
Now let's have a look at our backwards
looking financial ratios for valuation, EV
over EBIT and EV over EBITDA.
And these calculations are very
straightforward based on calculations that
we've looked at before.
EV over EBIT is enterprise value over
earnings before interest and taxes.
And EV over EBITDA is enterprise value
over earnings before interest, taxes,
depreciation and amortization.
And don't forget, it's important to
remember that enterprise value includes
market capitalization plus total debt
minus cash.
And yes, we have our EBIT and EBITDA
calculations at the bottom of the screen
there that we just looked at in the
financial statements of the company that
we just looked at.
So with these valuation metrics, these
ratios, we have to be, again, very careful
as traders and portfolio managers, how we
interpret them.
In traditional finance theory, the
enterprise value to earnings before
interest and taxes ratio is a metric used
to determine if a stock is undervalued or
overvalued.
And we put those words in quotations.
So if a stock is either cheap or expensive
relative to its peer group.
In relative peer group terms, traditional
finance theory says that a low EV over
EBITDA means a stock is cheap or
undervalued.
And if it's high means it's expensive or
overvalued.
But as traders and portfolio managers, we
know there's fallacies to this approach.
We know it not to be true.
So as traders and portfolio managers, we
know that there's going to be major flaws
to the traditional finance theory
approach.
We learned this from our price earnings
analysis.
Nothing is ever cheap or expensive.
The PE valuation, if you recall, is the
level at which the market is willing to
pay for or sell the earnings of the
company.
Similarly, the EV over EBITDA ratio is the
valuation level at which the market is
willing to pay for or sell the earnings of
the company before interest expenses and
tax expenses.
Also, we know what the limitations are of
enterprise value, which is on the top line
of our ratio.
So we have our four reservations here, as
in how is the debt being used?
What are the quality of the operations of
the company?
The market, the market obviously knows
already what the debt and cash position of
the company is, and it's a backwards
looking measure.
So if the market knows the debt and cash
position of a company already, do you
really think the market is that stupid
that they don't already know the interest
expense of the debt, tax expenses,
tax expenses, and even the depreciation
and amortization numbers from the last set
of publicly available financial accounts.
Of course, the market knows this
information.
And also, when you think of the EV
calculation of live market capitalization,
so the market cap plus debt minus cash,
the debt and cash element is backwards
looking from financial accounts, and the
market cap number is the livestock price
multiplied by the amount of shares
outstanding in issue.
So what is driving the dynamic part of the
calculation of EV is the live market cap.
So essentially, if we're using backwards
looking numbers at the EV level plus
market cap, so static numbers like debt
and cash,
backwards looking static numbers plus a
dynamic forward looking number, market
cap, and that makes up EV.
When we divide this by EBIT or even
EBITDA, it's the market cap that's
potentially driving the EV over EBITDA
ratio.
Unless, of course, we're using the market
cap number at the time of the financial
accounts, in which case, EV over EBIT is
even worse in terms of usefulness,
because it's a totally backwards looking
metric.
So if we are using the dynamic number for
market cap, and we are using the backwards
looking numbers for debt and cash on the
top line to make enterprise value,
price value, and we divide that by
backwards looking numbers for EBITDA, then
market cap, the dynamic market cap is
driving the EV over EBITDA ratio,
which means it's very similar to price
earnings ratio, except it's backwards
looking numbers that are being used in
addition to the forward looking number of
market cap,
which is made up of price and outstanding
shares.
So, what we are using this for in our
process is, again, for either supporting
or non-supporting, confirming or
non-confirming information of our forward
looking valuation metrics of both PE and
PEG ratio.
So, there is a very valid argument here
that states that market capitalization
already reflects the numbers included in
the enterprise value and EBIT
calculations,
because it's reflected in the share price
plus future expectations of the business
operation.
Why? Because the share price is the market
and the market is forward looking.
Now, traditional finance theory would have
you believe that enterprise value, EBIT
and EBITDA numbers matter more than price
and or forward earnings,
because the information for EV, EBIT and
EBITDA is already reported information.
It's real. It's tangible. And yes, it's
true that reported information like
enterprise value, EBIT and EBITDA numbers
that have and include backwards looking
static information is real and tangible.
But we are forward looking traders. We are
looking for edge and we trade on
expectation of opportunity.
The real question for us as traders is
whether enterprise value over EBIT or
enterprise value over EBITDA, for example.
So, the information adds anything
incremental to our forward PE measures.
So, our valuation measures of our expected
future in a stock.
Similarly, the same arguments apply to
enterprise value over EBITDA calculations
as above with EBIT.
So, we have even more reservations with EV
over EBITDA, we are simply adding back
depreciation and amortization to EBIT to
get a higher profit number.
So, let's say, for example, we are
operating in a highly capital intensive
industry.
And we're adding back a lot of DNA expense
for, say, a mining operation.
Do we really think that the market is so
stupid that they don't know that the
mining business owns and operates mines
with sizable fixed assets and capital
expenditure?
Can we really value a mining business by
analyzing earnings and completely
forgetting about DNA expense and drawing
sensible conclusions?
Of course not. The market already knows it
exists and takes it into consideration.
On the top line of the ratio, we have
enterprise value, which includes debt.
And on the bottom line, we have EBITDA,
which includes depreciation and
amortization.
But the debt for the company has probably
been used to buy the equipment that
creates the actual depreciation and
amortization.
So, again, as EBITDA is a better measure
for highly capital intensive industries
and EBITDA is a better measure for low
capital intensive industries,
when we're looking at operational
performance, EV over EBIT and EV over
EBITDA apply in the same way,
but also including the limitations of
enterprise value versus market cap.
So, always bear this in mind when
processing the quant and measuring stocks
relative to each other and in absolute
terms.
So, in terms of our trade idea generation
processing, how do we use EV, EBIT,
EBITDA, EV over EBIT and EV over EBITDA?
What is the usefulness here and what do we
use it for?
Well, in our trade idea generation
processing, we can, of course, add columns
to our spreadsheets to include EV, EBIT,
EBITDA and EV over EBIT and EV over EBITDA
and make comparisons across a sector, so
across stocks.
However, we have to understand the
interpretation properly.
We've seen the drawbacks of EV and EBIT
and EBITDA, so we have to be very careful
with our interpretation.
Our starting point in processing is
identifying what the market likes and
dislikes, then moving on to ask the
questions, why?
Why does the market like a particular
stock?
Why does the market dislike a particular
Why does something trade on a premium?
Why does something trade on a discount?
What is the justification for the premium?
What is the justification for the
discount?
And we continue with lines of inquiry.
So, we always start in our table with the
following columns.
Stock price.
Market cap.
EPS last year.
Last reported EPS.
So, EPS zero.
Forward-looking one-year EPS.
The current year.
EPS one.
Next year's EPS.
EPS two.
Earnings growth.
Forward-looking.
In the first year.
The current year.
EG one.
Earnings growth.
In the following year.
EG two.
Price earnings ratio.
Forward-looking.
Current year.
One.
PE one.
PE two.
Next year.
For the second year.
PE one.
Next year.
For the second year.
PEG one.
For the current year.
One year forward-looking.
The current year.
PEG one.
And PEG two.
The PEG ratio.
For next year.
And then.
When we have identified.
Positive.
And negative outliers.
We move.
To the next level.
Of our quantum processing.
And we start.
Looking.
For the reasons.
Why.
The market likes.
Certain stocks.
And why the market.
Dislikes.
Certain stocks.
And what are the justifications.
Behind it.
So.
What we do is.
We then include.
Further.
Financial metrics.
So.
We include.
Revenue growth.
Enterprise value.
EBIT.
And EBITDA.
To our positive.
And negative.
Outliers.
And if we choose.
To do so.
We can do.
Extra work.
On the whole sector.
To get.
A bigger picture.
Understanding.
Of why.
Money.
Like.
Certain stocks.
And why money.
Dislikes.
Certain stocks.
And what are the.
Justifications.
For.
The premiums.
And discounts.
Of stocks.
To each other.
Relative.
In a certain.
Sector.
And.
When we do.
Our work.
If we see.
That's.
Enterprise value.
And the.
EV.
Over EBIT.
And EV.
Over EBITDA.
Valuation.
Ratios.
If we see.
That they agree.
With.
Price.
Earnings.
Then we move on.
To.
To the next.
Level.
Of our.
Process.
Of.
Discovering.
More.
Stock.
Information.
If not.
We continue.
Our work.
To find out.
Why.
There's a discrepancy.
And.
We keep.
Asking.
The obvious.
Questions.
To see.
If it.
Adds.
Anything.
To our.
Understanding.
Of a.
Stocks.
Valuation.
Relative.
To others.
In the sector.
Additionally.
Because.
We know.
The limitations.
Of some.
Of these.
Backwards.
Looking.
Metrics.
Like.
EV.
Ebit.
And.
Dot.
We can.
Also.
Look.
For.
Public.
Information.
And.
If there's.
Any.
Forward.
Looking.
Guidance.
That's.
Recently.
Being.
Published.
By.
Management.
On.
Debt.
And.
Cash.
Levels.
For.
EV.
And.
For.
EBIT.
And.
EBITDA.
Numbers.
So.
If.
The.
Management.
Is.
Actually.
Out.
There.
Talking.
About.
The.
Future.
Expected.
Levels.
Of.
Debt.
And.
Cash.
This.
Can.
Actually.
Change.
Our.
Up.
To.
Date.
Picture.
Of.
Enterprise.
Value.
And.
For.
EBIT.
And.
EBITDA.
If.
Management.
Are.
Out.
There.
Guiding.
Towards.
Publicly.
Guiding.
Cash.
And.
For.
EBIT.
And.
EBITDA.
Versus.
The.
Last.
Set.
Annual.
Accounts.
Which.
Is.
Backwards.
Looking.
And.
Then.
Because.
Of.
That.
We.
Can.
And.
EV.
Over.
EBITDA.
Multiples.
Are.
Financial.
Ratios.
Or.
Valuations.
Based.
On.
These.
Numbers.
Of.
Our.
Screen.
Session.
Covering.
Our.
Second.
Forward.
Looking.
Metric.
Peg.
Ratio.
And.
Our.
Backwards.
Looking.
Financial.
Measures.
That.
Are.
In.
The.
First.
Stage.
Of.
The.
Overall.
Trade.
Idea.
Generation.
Okay, guys, so what did we look at there?
Well, we looked at peg ratio, and we also
looked at
additional accounting metrics that help us
in our trade idea generation process in
the quant phase.
So we looked at the interpretation of peg
ratio, and through our example, you will
have also noticed
some drawbacks of peg ratio that we have
to watch out for. You're going to
encounter this more in
further videos in the video series,
especially when we get to short ideas. So
when we start looking at
X growth stocks, turnaround stories, and
value traps. So we never ever, of course,
forget our
interpretation of peg ratio. But we have
to make sure that we don't fall ever into
statistical
traps where we misinterpret numbers. We
have to use common sense all the time
throughout the process.
So then we moved on from peg ratio, and we
looked at our backwards looking accounting
metrics, our accounting
quants that are backwards looking. And the
key here is, guys, to remember that it is
backwards looking.
We look to these measures for further
clarification as to why the market may
actually like or dislike a certain
stock. And we are cognizant of their uses,
the accounting metrics uses, and their
drawbacks. We do not use this information
to trade on it.
We don't take positions based on these
numbers. We use them because it's useful
during the identification or discovery
phase in quant processing.
So we try and understand what is going on
behind valuation. So P and peg ratio. And,
of course, what's behind the earnings
growth rates and the revenue growth rates.
It's kind of like peeling back the layers
of an onion. But remember, we are still in
the discovery phase. We haven't come up
with a long idea or a short idea at this
stage. We are in the discovery
phase and we do not trade on past
information. So we only trade on forward
looking information. Always remember that.
Now, we're going to move on to the next
video.
And actually, the next two videos, we're
going to be looking at the mechanics of
long trade ideas. First, in the next
video, and the video after that, the
mechanics of short trade ideas. In the
next video, what is also included is an
extremely useful section, which is going
to be given by Chris Quill.
And he's going to show you in a
spreadsheet class how to actually organize
stock data and process it properly in the
quant phase.
So let's move over to the next video,
guys, and I'll see you back at the desk a
bit later on.